hace siete meses este hombre de 51 años
descubrió que padece una enfermedad que
todavía genera discriminación
yo estaba en casa y cuando me levanté mi
cuerpo estaba lleno de pequeñas manchas
no sabía lo que era fui al médico y
pensó que era viruela del mono Yo quiero
sin embargo el diagnóstico fue
inesperado enfermedad de hansen popu
lar medida como lepra yo no tuve miedo
el problema principal es contárselo a
las personas no todo el mundo sabe lo
que es la enfermedad de Hansel hay mucho
prejuicio Hoy es un día importante
porque Fernando va a empezar su
tratamiento en la fundación Osvaldo cruz
de Río de Janeiro es todo más referencia
en la investigación científica en Brasil
cuando empiece a tomar el remedio la
única cosa que le pasa a todo el mundo
es que su orina se va a quedar muy roja
a pesar de ser el segundo país del mundo
con más casos según la Organización
Mundial de la Salud todavía hay mucha
desinformación
lo que importa para la enfermedad de
hansen es hacer un diagnóstico precoz y
un tratamiento precoz sólo así vamos a
poder evitar la incapacidad la
deformidad y el estigma la enfermedad de
hansen no es tan contagiosa como se
piensa se contrae por las vías
respiratorias pero solo tras una
convivencia prolongada con algún enfermo
no va a haber problemas porque sabemos
que esta enfermedad tiene vas a quedar
bien solo tienes que medicarte
correctamente Fernando no va a tener que
pagar nada por la atención médica ni por
los medicamentos el sistema Público de
salud cubre todos los gastos
es un año de tratamiento y se cura al
100% Durante un año una vez por mes
vendré aquí para hacer la revisiones
para ver cómo estoy
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
espere erradicar esta enfermedad en 2030
hasta Entonces Fernando Espera que para
él sea tan solo un recuerdo